cet après midi j'étais à l' usine mon
usine
j'ai regardé la france à travers la
vitre savez ce genre de vitres là je
peux comment ça s'appelle en sécurité
pourquoi qu'un imbécile a dit me
balancer un boulon dedans il me la
[ __ ] en l'air
j'étais encore sous le choc
une scène très pénible avec les délégués
syndicaux
j'avais dit vous les clefs vous les
voulez mais voilà si j'avais pas dit
poisson d'avril au dernier moment il me
le piquer mon frère est entré avec son
beau visage buriné par le farniente
je dis comment ça va tu es vieux parce
qu'il s'était fait des ampoules aux
paupières
à force de dormir
regardez tous les deux la foule des
ouvriers qui s'écoulait de la sortie 830
personnes quand même plus 80 noir
et 120 femmes
au total un millier de personnes un
millier de salaire je sentais son odeur
de vétiver derrière moi il m'a dit de
savoir caverneuse bientôt plus personne
n'aura plus rien plus rien y est plus un
club de golf plus un van gogh rien ou
lamento france
ouf nous mène-t-il pour moi j'ai mon
dossier des impôts là on me reproche
mais chevaux de course mais je suis la
vraie un cheval de course
sap est moins qu'une secrétaire et nous
en parlions avec les autres la ssii
d'encouragement de la race chevaline
mais la race chevaline elle va
décourager mon yacht mon yacht 40 mètres
de long
quatre moteurs six marins
je vous passe l'urssaf et vous savez ce
qu'on fait mouiller août
on longe le bord du port de cannes parce
que mon épouse moeurs de peur repas une
femme malade
le climat social lui donne de l'asthme
son seul dérivatif c'est de rajeunir
secret nuit et jour
moralité en trois ans à la radio ni
d'une heure on longe le bord ont fait
des huit à l'intérieur du port et on
revient au mouillage mais s'appuie stick
qui ont gènes qui ont jeune homme fait
une fois que j'entends ça pour quoi vous
servez vous d'un avion privé
parce que jaunir attendant on l'avion
est-il me prenne dessus je mens pas non
non j'étais obligé de dire à mon
personnel je ne peux pas vous garder je
n'aime pas la campagne on l'avait une
paire d'émigrer enfin bon équivalent
fournit un couple d'émigrés aux immigrés
relâchez pas comment il faut dire ce
sont comme dit mon épouse on sait pas où
ils vont d'où ils viennent alors
l'immigré émigrés servions même derrière
eux mêmes au demeurant des gens discrets
ils ont accepté un salaire pour deux
elle elle tient la maison elle fait la
cuisine lui les loger dans son lit et en
échange on lui demande d'aidé un peu au
jardinage à la maçonnerie
l'entretien de la ferme
au gardiennage de nuit il conduit la
voiture
il a réparé quand elle est en panne
on a trois rugissent en occupe
et coupent les arbres bon je leur fais
une salle de bain qu'est ce qu'ils
foutent de d'un du charbon du charbon ma
mère et moi non plus et moi tu peux
faire graphique par l'inspection du
travail
où voulez vous qu'il m'est très charmant
puisque la salle de bains de la cad
c'est pas la cerise sur le gâteau ça
c'est pas la cerise sur le gâteau
attendant la maison capital vers les
cimes fans dessus je mens pas mais ponk
là et tous les sans emploi je crée
l'autre jour un de mes livres y y et
diane de villandry se prend une épine
dans une pâte
voilà à 180 heures à ferrari pour foncer
chez le vétérinaire au croisement
personnes tracteur j'ai continué
galériens voyage avait quand même mon
aileron arrière droit spécialement car
aussi en italie par le couturier
giovanni tortelli qui carrosse mais
voiture et ma femme ouais mais l'ont
arraché ça tout le monde s'en fout mais
derrière moi le paysan bassin fracturé
gendarmerie ambulanciers brancardier 2
me tarde pourrir le chemin y croise les
pompiers parce que le tracteur s'était
renversée incendies dans les cultures
affolement à l'hôpital mais
saperlipopette je fais travailler toute
une région
je fais travailler toute une région
alors 1%
ouais sécurité sociale par exemple je
suis allé voir mon contrôleur des
contributions et lui dit simplement
combien gagnez vous combien gagnez vous
livrez pont temps je lui dis eh bien le
1%
quand on me réclame sur mon revenu
représente cette fois votre salaire
il est resté de marbre alors j'étais
obligé de dire ma femme je ne peux plus
te garder je ne peux plus l'état me
prends tous qu ils te prennent aussi qui
se chargent de dois ma poule jeu de
nationalise non partir changer d'horizon
de moeurs et coutumes racines partir
loin pour se faire naturaliser
il faut remplir un formulaire 1 pour
quel pays
optez vous deux pour quelles raisons
alors j'ai rempli et j'attends un monaco
2 pour la vue